imagination that one word sums up the
way that I see Confucius the Analects
and the influence of his teachings
Confucius's critics dismissed him as a
narrow-minded pendant but I think he was
anything but that he offers us
invaluable insights on how to live our
lives don't just earn your keep and rest
on your days off he urged us in effect
look learn imagine teach live your work
and certainly don't just work to live if
you can help it think about it ponder it
and find elements of lasting reflection
even in the simplest of daily activities
that's Confucius for me listen to the
following quotations from Chapter seven
of the Analects in which Confucius
reflects on his own life we're going to
examine the Analects more methodically
in the future but for now just taking
these snippets from the text that show
Confucius's imaginative side they bear a
hint of what I'm getting at Analects 719
the Duke of Xu asked so Liu about
Confucius so Liu did not respond when he
heard of this the master said I didn't
you just say
Confucius finds himself so engrossed in
his studies that he forgets to eat he
delights in his interactions until he
forgets to worry and he has not even
come to understand that old age is just
around the corner Analects 7:20 the
master said I am NOT a person who was
born with a gift for gaining knowledge
instead my devotion to study of the
classical past propels me forward as I
seek knowledge
Confucius taught his followers a nuanced
even magical social relational way of
living and learning in the world he can
teach us too if we will only listen and
resist are all too ready impulses to see
a straight-laced moralizing we're much
richer teaching really was taking place
I hope to show you why and how we can
make in fuchsias as text into a lifetime
teaching tool for us our families our
communities and the larger world just as
Confucius intended
a little background about my perspective
on Confucius will help you understand
why I find his ideas so compelling and
vital when I was growing up I read a
book about practice persistence and life
written by one of my favorite
competitors the golfer Jack Nicklaus
just about anything Nikolas had to say
about practice training and competition
went right into my plans for my own
future
in fact I found Nicholas's book golf my
way so useful that it gave me a template
for leading my own life I filled several
notebooks of my jotting is about what he
had to say about life beyond the world
of competition to say the least the book
spoke to me but like like itself not
everything in it seemed perfect
one of Nicholas's anecdotes seemed just
a little bit off even in the midst of my
youthful hero-worship it was a brief and
beautiful story about his own father
yet it tripped me up in my recollection
and I can see that the memory may not be
accurate after all these years Nicolas
essentially wrote when I was young my
father was a busy insurance executive
but no matter how busy or preoccupied he
was with his work when he walked through
the front door at 5 o'clock work was
gone
so what could sound off about that let
me assure you that even as an ambitious
nine-year-old I understood precisely
what was meant Nicholas framed his
father's habits as an ideal and I
certainly was able to see the value of
his message of fatherly devotion I could
even see how the way that his father
compartmentalised his life could benefit
his children his spouse perhaps the
whole neighborhood the problem for me
was I had another model Furlan in mind
when my own busy parents walked through
the door after work they set to
discussion with their children about
English literature more than a little
English grammar anthropology history
philosophy news politics neighborhood
issues and more everything was on the
table literally and figuratively and I
soaked in the happy engagement with
ideas
for me Nicholas's example seemed tinny
even though I understood that he admired
the way his father avoided burdening his
family with the pressures of daily work
for me work meant the world of ideas and
it was not a burden
it seemed entirely natural that parents
would share their work with their
families maybe just maybe the problem
lay in how we interpreted work
it wasn't until a decade later when I
was in college that I came to understand
that I was not alone in seeing the work
world in this manner I had picked up a
slender volume that I already knew to be
a classic of social thought see right
mills --is the sociological imagination
and there before me were the sentiments
I had felt all along
Mills didn't write about his work as if
it was a job for him it seemed to be an
all-encompassing outlook on the world
the sociological imagination consists of
the capacity to shift from one
perspective to another and in the
process to build up an adequate view of
a total society and of its components it
is this imagination of course that sets
off the social scientist from the mere
technician adequate technicians can be
trained in a few years the sociological
imagination can also be cultivated there
is an unexpected quality about it
perhaps because its essence is the
combination of ideas that no one
expected were combined abble Mills spoke
right to my feelings even when I was
young it seemed that real imagination
and creativity had to be a full-time
occupation that it couldn't just be
turned on and off seemed as clear to me
as anything I had ever learned
Mills continued by underlining how
essential this combining of ideas that
he described really is and how
subjective and sometimes even uh NACA
demic it all feels there's a playfulness
of mind back of such combining as well
as a truly fierce drive to make sense of
the world which the technician as such
usually lacks perhaps he is too well
trained to precisely train since one can
be trained only in what is already known
training incapacitates one from learning
new ways it makes one rebel against what
is bound to be at first loose and even
sloppy
Mills continues but you must cling to
such vague images and notions if they
are yours and you must work them out for
it is in such forms that original ideas
if any almost always first appear
Mills is saying something profound here
he is saying that truly deeply
imaginative social thinkers cannot will
not could never close it down they are
always thinking always reflecting and
always learning new things about a
changing world
such imagination feeds on everyday
experience that we have and it goes so
far beyond simply earning a living as to
be in a different category of
entrepreneurship altogether go all in
Mills almost shouts at his readers risk
having loose sloppy and first draft
style ideas sense that this thing over
here and that thing over there might be
related
then Mull it over talk about it and dive
into more analysis don't sit on the
sidelines and don't check out after a
good day's work
live your work and then share it with
others
I think see right Mills was onto
something and I think in fuchsias would
have agreed with him people have a
thirst for knowledge and for lessons
they can internalize lessons that might
make them better individuals better
family members and better members of
larger communities at least in the West
we too often hear these lessons through
the voice of individual character but
what we are starved for often without
fully realizing it is a different kind
of lesson we want to know how to live
with integrity with others no amount of
personal integrity alone can work if we
don't know how to carry out our lives
with other people in community in
society when I teach social and cultural
theory every autumn I use advice columns
from the newspapers back when I was
growing up and Landers and Dear Abby
filled those pages now a new generation
of advice columnist is at work not to
mention the myriad advice we can get
from social media I tell my students
that they need to read the columns and
think about their readings in social and
cultural analysis to my mind many people
read these columns the wrong way you see
it is the questions that are important I
usually get bored by the answers looking
those questions teach us
well almost all of the Americans writing
about their problems frame the conflict
around character flaws in their own or
more often someone else's character but
it quickly becomes clear that
individualistic thinking will not solve
those problems what my students learn is
that living well in the world and
solving the big and little challenges
around us requires a remarkable
combination of ethical and social
imagination creating that imaginative
combination and being all-in for
learning and acting is exactly what
Confucius is Analects is about let me
show you what I mean
early on in the Analects in the second
chapter the Analects has this intriguing
little entry that reminds me of the
intellectual curiosity and social
ethical imagination that I learned from
see right Mills Analects - - the master
said the 300 items in the book of songs
can be concentrated into a single
expression charged forth without
swerving now while this may seem at
first glance to be a literary aside I
think of it quite otherwise as a call to
action that moves from learning to doing
and from text to action
charge forth without swerving reminds me
of what see right mill says when he
stresses that imagination and commitment
to continual research and learning is a
way of life for Confucius the book of
songs was a foundational text of his
culture and he admired it deeply and yet
as we will see later
Confucius did not imagine that it was
possible simply to read the book of
songs and somehow magically be able to
act in the world
take a look at a passage that we will
study in depth later Analects 13:5 the
master said if people can recite the 300
items in the book of songs yet still
fail to make use of that knowledge when
given an official position or when sent
abroad on diplomatic missions
what is the use of studying even though
they may have learned so much
what is the use of it to them so mere
recitation we might even say following
see right Mills mere technical ability
that is not enough there needs to be
real commitment the students Confucius
admirers need to be all in but let's
take another look at Confucius's
commitment to study that embraces one's
whole life this brief passage is as
succinct as it gets and yet it speaks to
Confucius his perspective that there is
no distance from deep learning it does
not stand offish it is immersed
intellect 620 the master said knowing
something is not as good as loving it
loving it is not as good as savoring it
think about the implications of this
perspective especially if you've come to
think of learning as something that
takes place from a neutral or objective
position
confucius seems to be saying something
else here and i don't think that it
means that one will be mired in sloppy
subjectivity rather i think that he is
saying that you have to love what you do
and how you learn and you need to savor
the process above all as Searight mills
might say such learning is a way of life
not a subject of study
another entry in the Analects gives us a
further perspective here Confucius
stresses that he will not let up until
he has gotten to the bottom of a problem
no matter who asks it he will just keep
thinking letting it drum into his
thoughts percolating really take a
listen handle x98 the master said do I
have great knowledge no I do not yet if
an ordinary rustic asks me a question
and I have no answer I will pursue it
from beginning to end until I have gain
deeper insight think about times when
you have been completely into learning
something you know you have just think
and when you were you likely pursuit it
from beginning to end until you gain
deeper insight okay and then what did
you do well you probably taught it to
others you may not have done this in a
formal way
but you conveyed it to others this is
what deep reflection for Confucius means
you craft an understanding on your own
and sometimes with others and then you
pass it on to others let's let Confucius
wrap up this idea for us and like seven
- the master said to persist in gaining
knowledge to study without flagging and
to teach without tiring are these not
the qualities I have
Confucius was a learner and a teacher he
wanted others to be too and his lesson
has persisted for 2,500 years I have
been delighted to discover how
Confucius's ideas on the ethical and
social imagination resonate with people
today and how much eagerness there is on
the part of students to explore them
when I first signed on to teach this
course I decided that a good way to work
through the key ideas surrounding
Confucius and the Analects would be to
teach a class about the topic that's
what I always do when I want to explore
something so I set out to teach
Confucius and the world the very next
semester at my college the college is
quite small and deeply committed to
discussion of key texts so we keep
classes small to even our larger classes
tend to have no more than 25 students
and the target for our history 150
introductory seminars that was the
audience I tapped for Confucius and the
world was 15 students well 40 signed up
without a prompt just a paragraph long
blurb in the registration materials
telling prospective students that we
would like to make sense of Confucius
and his dense little treatise the
Analects when I saw the enrollment
number I asked the Dean if I could offer
a second section so that we could have
back-to-back seminars instead of a big
lecture class and now there are from
just one semester forty students at one
small College who know a great deal
about the philosophy of Confucius and
how it could change their lives they
have tapped into the creative
imagination that Confucius taught and
see right Mills taught many centuries
later and now they are ready to tackle
even larger questions about where
Confucius is thinking fits into a
complex Chinese tradition as well as an
extraordinarily different Western
tradition it is exactly this goal that
drives these lectures about Confucius in
the Analects and it is certainly not
only at one small college in Wisconsin
that such transformations are taking
place
from the University of Hawaii to Harvard
and from Montana to Texas and all
through North America Europe and the
rest of the world courses in Chinese
philosophy have produced robust
enrollment figures even at a time when
many people Bellone the sheer
practicality of interests among students
something is going on we would do best
to listen to that hunger for
understanding
it wasn't always this way some time ago
I found myself in a conversation with a
grad student in philosophy at one of the
elite philosophy departments in the
United States I explained that I was in
the process of integrating Confucius's
philosophical teachings that was the
precise phrase I used in just something
that I found useful in and beyond my
studies of Chinese history and
anthropology I was completely unprepared
for his response though Confucius he
snorted and that Analects then he paused
Confucius has nothing to do with
philosophy it's just not philosophy
maybe it is a kind of Asian wisdom he
voiced that phrase with utter derision
it is not philosophy though
I wish I could say that this student who
is soon to become a professor was alone
in his opinion about the great Chinese
thinker one of the best books about
philosophy that I have ever read is
Brian McGee's memoir confessions of a
philosopher although McGee's book is
squarely about the Western philosophical
tradition he raises an important point
for all of us early on you see Magee
feels that the profession of philosophy
has failed us and exactly when we need
it most
he describes his own experience studying
philosophy at Oxford the 1950s and being
disgusted with what he regarded as the
tiny little questions about how we use
language favoured by analytical
philosophers of that era it wasn't until
he undertook a year of study at Yale in
the 1960s that in reading Immanuel
Kant's three critiques the critique of
Pure Reason the critique of practical
reason and the critique of judgment that
McGee found a philosopher who asked big
philosophical questions on what life in
our world is all about
but here's the problem Westerners tend
to think about big questions through one
of two lenses one of my colleagues has
spoken of these lenses as the microscope
and the telescope and I like his
characterization sometimes we
contemplate the great structures of the
universe or the vast sweep of human
history through our interpretive
telescopes at other times we study the
tiny structures that shape our
microscopic knowledge from DNA to
subatomic particles but both lenses
embody the Western emphasis on logic
rationality and a highly individualistic
view of the world confucius certainly
doesn't seem to be looking at the world
through those lenses or to be asking the
big questions of which brian mcgee spoke
Immanuel Kant asked how we know what we
think we know he asked about our
aesthetic standards and he argued for
uncompromising ethical standards how
could Confucius ever compete with that
well I think he does a colleague and I
were talking about this matter recently
at a big comparative philosophy
conference in Hawaii we both struggle to
find a way to sum up with the 500
entries in the Analects are all about
and then just as our bus pulled up to
our destination we both blurted out as
solid and answer as I have ever heard
they're about getting good at life
exactly Confucius's and like to do deal
with the big questions they don't get
any bigger than how we should live our
lives with and among others
but I freely admit that early in my
career I had my doubts about Confucius
when I started out in Chinese studies
the consensus at least among most
students and many professors was that
Confucius was an impractical rule making
boar the general view was that he had
little to teach us in modern society and
that the Analects was only a value for
what it could tell us about China's
imperial past the idea that Confucius
could be the carrier of a vital message
of a way of knowing and acting in the
world struck us as nonsense we just
weren't buying it decades ago when
people asked me about Confucius I told
them that I saw much more subtlety and
spontaneity in the teachings of
enigmatic thinkers who mocked Confucius
and his followers with great relish in
the centuries during and after Confucius
lived it was another scholar one who
once had also been skeptical of
Confucius who changed my mind the
philosopher Herbert finger ette wrote a
splendid book called Confucius the
secular as sacred and it led many of us
in Western academic circles to rethink
our approaches to Confucius in the
Analects I first read finger at spoke
right after college just as I began
haltingly at first to read the Analects
in Chinese here is how finger Rhett
describes his own discovery of the sage
when I began to read Confucius I found
him to be a prosaic and parochial
moralizer his collected sayings the
Analects seemed to me an archaic
irrelevance later and with increasing
force I found him a thinker with
profound insight and with an imaginative
vision of man equal in its grandeur to
any I know I was floored by this
statement of Confucius as potential
relevance not just to something I
thought of his traditional Chinese
philosophy but to my own life as well
suddenly I realized that my readings the
Analects have been mechanical that in
--see right Mills's language I was just
going through the motions thinking like
a technician when I first read Confucius
is Analects thing read continues
explaining his own changed perspective
increasingly I have become convinced
that Confucius can be a teacher to us
today a major teacher not one who merely
gives us a highly exotic perspective on
the ideas or any current he tells us
things not being said elsewhere things
needing to be said he has a new lesson
to teach
what finger Rhett touches upon is the
thoroughly engaged nature of knowledge
and action in Confucius's Analects there
is no telescope no microscope no
rational and dispassionate aloofness for
subjects at hand Confucian engagement
differs radically from many Western
ideals of disengage study from the
outside you must be all in to comprehend
the Analects and the lessons of which
finger Rhett speaks you must enter the
conversation
what conversation am i speaking of
flex exchange of questions and answers
assertions and observations challenges
and retorts that make up the gentle
pedagogical rhythms of the Analects
it welcomes the reader who is willing to
engage with it but learning to do so can
admittedly be challenging let's look at
some examples of the kinds of exchanges
I'm talking about so you can see how you
might enter the conversation of the
Analects yourself a large number of
entries and Confucius's Analects set up
a special kind of social scene it is one
in which someone sometimes dukes and
territorial governors other times his
own students ask him a question his
answers can help us to enter the growing
dialogue and I would urge you to listen
for these social interactions as we
proceed Analects 17/8 the master said
Zulu have you heard of the six negative
qualities in the six positive qualities
no I haven't replied Zulu well sit down
then said the master I will instruct you
wanting to be consummate in conduct but
not wanting to study that is a first
flaw and it will lead to fatuousness
wanting knowledge but not wanting to
study that is a second flaw and it will
lead to rootlessness
the master continues wanting to be true
to one's word but not wanting to study
that is a third flaw and it leads to
impairment wanting to be upright but not
wanting to study that is a fourth flaw
and it leads to impudence wanting to be
brave without wanting to study that is a
fifth flaw and it leads to disorder
finally wanting to be solid and firm but
not wanting to study that is a sixth
flaw and it leads to fool hardiness in
many ways this kind of entry teaches the
reader or listener how to enter the
conversation
I'm reminded of an anecdote in one of TS
Eliot's essays he said of his form of
highly innovative poetry that the poems
themselves could teach the reader how to
read the poetry in other words reading
it helped one to learn that something
profound new and different was going on
in the passage you just heard
Confucius uses a series of ordinary
words and contrast them with study or
not studying
people who confronted Confucius's
teachings during the masters lifetime as
well as in the decades and centuries
that followed we're hearing something
different from the ways they used those
words
Confucius used concepts in new and
sometimes startling ways interactions
like the one you just heard are an
example of Confucius teaching his
listeners how to think creatively
imaginatively and to continue to do so
for themselves and for others
if you're still struggling to grasp how
the text of the Analects works don't
despair there will be many more
opportunities in this course to
understand it and rest assured that
you're not alone I know plenty of people
who earnestly wish to understand
Confucius's message and have tried often
repeatedly to do so a close friend and
colleague of mine confided recently that
every few years I pick up a translation
of the Analects and try to read it again
I know that I want to grasp what
Confucius has to say but I just give up
after a few dozen pages I can't seem to
understand where it is going no amount
of hard work or perseverance ever makes
a difference
I can't just muscle my way through the
text
Analects are indeed difficult to
penetrate at the outset but if you can
master the essentials of reading them
you will find yourself greatly rewarded
and your life enriched as many
persistent readers have discovered to do
so requires that you enter the world of
the text in a way that is different from
the one in which most of us were trained
imagine what it was like in a much
earlier era when information at the
click of a button was a thing of utter
fantasy imagine a world in which the
gift of a book could change your life
forever imagine a world in which you
didn't just read but read reread and
read again and lived a book it is so far
from the way that we think today that we
need to remind ourselves of the power
that a single book can contain
Confucius's Analects contains that kind
of transformative power and you can
experience it for yourself if you
approach the book in the right way it
must be read reread and lived